so what would you do right now in
ukraine if you were the president
putin uses the n word i call it the n
word he uses the n word the nuclear word
all the time that's a no no you're not
supposed to do that he uses it on a
daily basis and everybody's so afraid so
afraid so afraid and as they're afraid
he uses it more and more that's why he's
doing the kind of things he's doing
he's doing them because he thinks
nobody's gonna ever attack us because
they're all stupid and they're afraid to
talk i totally agree with him okay so
what would you do instead of excuse me
it's
a little complicated
instead of
you know cow towing instead of
biden saying oh
he's got nuclear weapons he keeps saying
he's got no
we have better
weapons that we have the greatest
submarine power in history what would
you say and do i would say we have far
more than you do far
far more powerful than you and you can't
use that word ever again you cannot use
the nuclear word ever again harry is
whipped do you know the expression i'm
familiar with i won't use the full
expression but harry is whipped like no
person i think i've ever seen i'm not a
fan of megan yeah i'm not a fan and i
wasn't right from the beginning i think
poor harry is being led around by his
nose okay do you think he's gonna win i
do i've been a very good predictor as
you know i predicted almost everything
it'll end and it'll end bad and i wonder
if harry's gonna go back on his hands
and knees and say please you know i
think harry has been led down a path if
you were the queen is it at the stage
now would you remove their royal title i
would the only thing i disagree with the
queen on probably one of the only things
ever
is that i think she should have said if
that's your choice fine
but you no longer have titles you no
longer and frankly
don't come around he has been so
disrespectful to the country and i think
he's an embarrassment the latest poll
says if the 2024 election was held
tomorrow you would beat joe biden by six
points and kamala harris by 11 points in
other words you would be re-elected
president of the united states so are
you going to run again well you know for
reasons of campaign finance and
everything i'm not allowed to say but
let me just say this i think a lot of
people are going to be very happy
so you want me
i love our country our country is going
to hell i think a lot of people are
going to be very happy you're going to
run i'm not going to say that but i
think people are going to be happy but
another thing to you it's i've watched
this whole debate rage and you've been
completely
unflagging in your refusal to accept
defeat you know why though you know why
because if our country doesn't have fair
and free elections and if our country
doesn't have borders we don't have a
country okay we have crooked corrupt
elections here's what i was saying and
i've proven it is what i would say to
you i believe it was a free and fair
election and that you lost you don't
really believe that that's my belief
well then you're a fool however then
you're a fan maybe i am a fool i'd be on
the fool in in this conversation you're
a fool and you haven't studied it now
how could i not talk about exactly how
our incredible interview finally ended
after all it's made global headlines
because apparently the promo was rigged
donald trump himself issued two
statements branding it fake news well
here's what really happened i haven't
mentioned it that's it no yeah yeah last
question four times
this was a 20-minute interview oh sorry
listen this was a 20-minute interview
okay let's go that was a great interview
yeah that's fine thank you very much i
really appreciate it
turn the camera off
well there you have it in full call it
whatever you like mr president did leave
pretty angry it certainly wasn't a happy
ending
and frankly i'm a bit disappointed about
that because i did think it was a
brilliant interview we agreed on a
number of issues we disagreed vehemently
about others but you were extremely
entertaining
very direct in some of the things you
were saying it's made headlines around
the world and i just hope that now
you've seen the whole thing in totality
we can put our little spat behind us you
can park your two statements perhaps to
a little corner of your office and maybe
even see it in your heart to pick up the
phone
and we can have a virtual cup of tea you
in palm beach me and london
milk no sugar congratulations because i
think your first week
64
million
impressions or hits or viewers or
whatever and and i saw that because the
topic the first one was about donald
trump and donald trump was very proud of
the fact that he was the subject and 64
million hits but then at the end of the
statement it goes
great great great ratings but he's over
you know something happened to him piers
morgan not the same guy that he used to
be even what they had to happen to him i
think you know you've got a great
interview a great interview when a a
recently departed president of the
united states issues not one not two but
three statements so far about the
interview all of them with conflicting
reports from his mind about how he
thinks it went on the one hand he
thought it was tedious on the other hand
he thought it was brilliant he thought
the ratings were fantastic but i'm
finished and over the hill and in fact
at a rally last night i think in
nebraska he announced that i'm
officially crazy this crazy pierce
morgan did you see that show
piers morgan thank you sir
piers morgan show you see piers morgan
he sort of had it i think piers is
over the hill
he opened the show with an interview of
me i did him a favor i didn't want to do
a stupid show it's on
fox nation what is fox nation what is it
they're gonna love me when i say what is
fox it's on fox nation he opened with
great ratings when he did me
and then after my interview was finished
he bombed and he's now down over 70
percent and
maybe they'll someday learn that
maybe they should hire me as an anchor
should i go to work and say we'll get
the greatest reading
we'll sit there and we'll riff i've got
to say herrera i would watch donald
trump if he did anchor a show like this
i mean i would him live and unfiltered
every night would be fantastic i doubt
he's going to do it but what was that i
mean i just felt that it's a massive
overreaction by donald trump to what was
actually when you watched it a really
insightful revealing interview which
most people i know saw it actually
thought he came out of it pretty well
i i saw it and that was the conclusion i
had pierre is a pretty good interview
you asked all the right questions the
necessary questions but as you know he
has
profoundly thin skin
he doesn't
suffer insults lightly he
has a rule you hit him he'll hit you
back
even if you didn't intend to hit him by
even asking a question that he viewed as
vaguely
you know impolite
he he carries that grudge
forever